comedy could be so therapeutic mm-hmm
and so you know like when things are
bothering you
there's like a certain sense of like hey
talk about this right now
because this is what's bothering you
yeah and then what you're doing is like
well this is bothering me but I can heal
yeah right yeah like there's a bit on
the new album where one of my friends
pointed out who's a comic he was like
dude that's a freakishly dark bit but
you made it funny and it's about my dad
almost giving my older brother the
beating of his life right but he was too
fat to take his belt off so we all just
had laughs and that's kind of how I view
life like is there a darkness there
absolutely but there's also a joy in in
the suffering there's a joy in the
moment and it's like hey man it goes by
so fast
find something to celebrate find
something to it cuz that's it they're so
funny we got that kind of happened to me
my mom there was this tree outside in
the backyard in RTN you know and
literally my mom would be like go get a
switch off that tree and that's how
that's how I would get whooped you know
what I mean so what kind of
psychological because you can't pick a
little oh really how about if I use the
back instead and then there used to be
like a hallway in my this apartment we
lived in we're like so there was like a
door at the end and if you walked
through the hallway it was like the
length of the apartment and you could
come in you know so it was like a long
way around nobody was like a roundabout
yeah you know so it was like so I would
run from my mom we would run in circle
she would be chasing me
fun times because in the middle of the
running we both started laughing that's
what happened with my dad was too fast
to get his goat off look I never saw my
fat big brother ever run he ran and the
whole family my dad's chasing my brother
and then the rest of the family's
chasing my dad chasing my mom's like
don't kill him I know we did a couple
laps from like living rooms through the
kitchen through the dining room through
the kitchen through the run and my dad
finally got him cornered and he was too
fat to get the belt off so so I get
around for my mom
but so the one night days I'm really in
trouble I don't know I remember of
course I remember what I did but she's
like go get a switch off the tree I go
out back and the trees gone they thank
you Jesus I know they they you know they
cut the tree down and so I have to go
back I go but that was like I was scared
cuz I was like the trees gone
she starts cracking up you know one of
the first times I was like you know this
humour thing there's something to this
like making people laugh to get out of
[ __ ]